how many people like you and i get high
on their own supply just because they
won somewhere else they become
delusional that they think the next
thing's going to work i think that as
soon as you give the vibe out to the
universe that you're smarter than that
you're better than you've got it rigged
you're finished
[Music]
the garyvee audio experience
all right podcast nation we are back as
i said uh many times with the befriends
nft project exploding i'll be doing less
interviews in 2022 but more meaningful
ones or people that i think can bring
you uh uh a lot of value and uh our
guest today is definitely someone who
will share friends and i've heard really
great things but we've never really been
able to chop up as a matter of fact it's
the first time we're really even jamming
together but um thomas toll is with us
i'm gonna let him uh
kind of give us a three minute five
minute five-minute two-minute kind of
comic book number one little bio and how
he sees himself or what things he's done
and then we'll kind of uh
shoot the [ __ ] about
um some of those themes and and kind of
where the world is my friend how are you
i'm good i'm good thank you for having
me on
i'm happy to do it so for everybody on
here
that you know
when they google you and says american
businessman how do you speak about
yourself
hopefully very little
that's always uh
feels awkward strange and
you know so uh
look i've i've been very fortunate in my
life there's no no question about it
and uh
what i enjoy doing is looking at
opportunities markets companies
uh and then applying innovation
technology and so forth to hopefully
give that company a uh a chance
to to do something both different and
profitable
um and i've gone through you know a
number of
iterations in my career from
uh being in tech venture capital uh my
background is in tech and finance
took a big left-hand turn in my life had
no media experience
but i was fascinated by the way movies
and television was financed and their
revenue streams this was back in 2004.
uh and thought i could bring
institutional capital to that ecosystem
uh built legendary into a a pretty
sizable company
um along the way
introduced who's listening what what is
legendary a production company
yeah so legendary uh was is a production
company that does
movies television there was a comic book
division there was a digital division
um you know etc i sold the company back
in 2016
and one of the things that happened
along the way
is using
data science
to do we felt like a much better job of
deploying capital not to make film and
television or to
predict how audiences would feel and all
that stuff i you know i had the chance
to partner with chris nolan and folks
like that so that on the creative side
that that worked well
but we were really the first company to
use
data science
to find people who were persuadable to
find audiences
and talk to them in a very
uh sort of bespoke way in order to cause
an outcome
and that that made a big difference for
the company
that led me
after selling it uh to form tulco which
i know is
not very imaginative in terms of the
name but it's a holding company you're
talking to somebody who's got vayner
vayner land i mean i'm i like
it just makes it easy
well in our case uh the joke of it was
they kept asking me to come up with a
name and it's a holding company right so
it's not a brand right and they kept
jokingly instead of calling it newco
they'd call it telco and one day they're
like look man we need to wire money so
what's the name of the company and that
i'd love to tell you a better story but
that's that's how that happened
and the idea behind telco was we go and
buy either whole companies or usually
controlling stakes in them and besides
providing uh the capital and and
hopefully some
business acumen
we also had telco labs which was sort of
a
you know i was always uh enamored with
bell labs and what bell labs meant in
terms of innovation so we had
practitioners of artificial intelligence
machine learning data science so we
would bring those
resources to bear in companies that
didn't traditionally have a lot of
innovation and would not have access to
folks like that and it's worked well you
know do you do you
think of yourself as an operator
well i certainly you know it was i ran
legendary and so forth but it's not my
it's not my favorite thing to do my
favorite thing is first go ahead i'm
sorry i finished your thought well no
i'm just going to say my favorite thing
to do is
to partner with great operators
uh and provide
capital
input you know access to strategic
financial strategic financial arbitrage
yes but i think also if i have any skill
sets which is certainly up for debate
it's looking at a business
or looking at a sector
and thinking about it differently
right and saying like seeing white space
seeing your face that but you know it's
funny i mean like let's actually break
this down because
even just listening to the way you're
deploying humility and a little
self-deprecation
because i understand it and i do it at
times though i'm a little bit more
comfortable being like look i'm really
good at this one thing and i suck [ __ ] i
usually go with i suck [ __ ] at these 99
things but i'm [ __ ]
really good at this one thing let's
break this down because i now i'm
starting to see where i may want to take
this we have a lot of people listening
up in 40 i mean what is it really
actually in eight minutes what's very
clear to me i'm like oh here's my
connection point with this other winning
player
there's a level of self-awareness
that i am hypothesizing that we share
that allows us to
squeeze the [ __ ] out of the things we
like and are good at
versus over obsessing at maybe some of
the things we're not as good at
and in that there's a real level of like
happiness and success
when i say that does that connect and
then more importantly for everyone who's
listening
what's the learning in that in their
world of what they may be good or not
good at
thoughts
well i i think there's a blend of
extreme
intellectual honesty
right being able to look at yourself and
if you can and it's a hard thing is to
put ego aside
and say what am i good at what am i not
good at
what makes me happy and fulfilled
and what are the things that even i even
though i know i wish i were better at it
is it worth spending the cycles those 10
000 hours to get good at something
versus using my time elsewhere
and you know the other thing that i
think in this day and age i'm not on any
social media and i'm not here to bash or
whatever else it's just not interesting
for me
and you know so because you have to
spend so much time curating and so forth
uh and i also know i'm bound to say
something stupid which then gets
amplified and so forth
so i try to be very comfortable with
look this is what i like
this is what i think i'm pretty good at
and i'm gonna stay on you know on that
highway um and at the same time i think
you also have to have
the conviction that look if you've you
know if you've done the homework and
you've convinced yourself that something
is
real important it's an opportunity then
even if there are a chorus of
well-meaning people telling you you're
you're stupid or you're wrong or you
shouldn't do this even if they're
well-intentioned you have to have the
convention conviction to say no no i
i've measured twice i'm going to cut
once and and on that note do you factor
in
regret
as a variable to why you're willing to
make that cut so when i hear you say
that
that's been the story of my life as well
i also am a little bit more like white
space new stuff right
one of the big factors in my world and
that is
i just know that when i'm 87 whether i
was right or wrong
i'll always regret not cutting that one
time because i've already gotten to that
convinced place and if god forbid i let
my dad or you if we became best friends
for 20 years and i respected you anybody
if i let them convince me otherwise that
i would be too accountable to knowing at
the end of the day was my call and i
would not be willing to point fingers
and then i would be disappointed in the
regret of not tasting the experience and
that actually drives me almost more than
any even more than thinking i'm gonna
win and make money and all that like
it's just like the fear of regretting it
being like [ __ ] because i'd rather die
on my sword than someone else's
i i think that's well said and and
frankly
i think if that
is
partnered if you will
with again that awareness to say
have i really thought about this
well i have any expertise have i
consulted with people
and have i convinced myself in a
rational fashion and now i am willing to
take that mountain yeah if you haven't
done that work
because there's plenty of times how many
people like you and i get high on their
own supply just because they won
somewhere else they become delusional
that they think the next thing's going
to work i i have to tell you that is
you know i uh
i think that as soon as you
give the vibe out to the universe that
you're smarter than that you're better
than you've got it rigged you're
finished i i i think the universe will
come back and teach you are you a are
you a bach i know you love football like
me and you've accomplished a lot of
things i want to buy the new york jets
do you have a sense of
do you like boxing or mma
yeah i mean look i'm completely
convinced that that's what happens to
great fighters
completely
well look at the end of the day you know
there's something certainly very primal
about
two people go into a ring and it's
pretty clear
most of the time at the end of it and i
think that
um
again you think about what it takes to
be a great fighter
it has to be you have to be crazy enough
and have enough resiliency and hubris to
enter that ring
but at the same time
you have to have
enough of check yourself
to say hey is it time to stop is it so i
think that's a really i'll show you
something keep talking i'm going to show
you something oh my goodness
you're going to lose viewers by the
minute if i just sit here
looking good all right so i just wrote
this book right this is where we're
going the whole way and it talks about
emotional ingredients and i'm listening
to you and obviously i've known about
your success from afar
and i'm getting excited because i'm like
man i think i really landed on something
with this concept of ingredients so here
are the ones that i value the fact that
you're talking right now for the last
seven minutes about number 10 and 11 in
combination and so few people
understand that 10 and 11
feel like they're opposites but when
mixed together like making a meal
that's what you're describing to me
right now i'm literally i don't know if
you see it i have goosebumps because you
have been talking for seven minutes
about
conviction
mixed equally with humility and that and
you know this a lot of people struggle
when you carry it's kind of how i think
about the world right now we're living
in a very you know this a very red and
blue world and i'm like it's [ __ ]
purple
it's if you can't if you don't go to
purple you're [ __ ] it's not
how are people walking i mean no matter
how conservative or liberal you are no
matter what if you do not have the
intellect or the humility or the
curiosity to understand that it's
[ __ ] purple and that's what you're
saying right now you are
you went right down a path right away
which i'm a huge fan of 10 and 11.
humility mixed with conviction because
your humility will protect you
because that's what you were talking
about doing the home that humility
allows you to stay curious and open to
somebody talking you out of it along the
way or making a point or a data set that
may make you look at it slightly
different no
i think that's exactly right and you
have hopefully some internal compass
that says has i have i earned this right
have i put the work in and the reason i
have conviction isn't because i read
something on the internet or the last
person i talked to said no it's i did
the work and therefore i've earned the
right to to dig in on this position
look at in terms of purple the thing
that i am hopeful of i love this country
uh you know i came from
very you know single mom poor background
this country afforded me the opportunity
to
to
you know
do what i've what i've been fortunate
enough to do and at the same time
i always think about the whole point of
this being the united states
is that it's a whole
big country of different cultures and
different things
but at the end of the day what's made
this country great is a belief in
certain things
and as soon as you
villainize the other side that it's not
just that we don't see it the same way
because i've had different life
experiences than you have but you're a
villain and now you're a bad person or
you're a dummy
i i just i think that that's we've lost
civility
yes on both sides and we are going to
need to lean into civility in purple or
were in deep trouble let's go to that
childhood real quick
worry you know i i was born in the
soviet union so talk about somebody who
really values yeah
so i don't remember it obviously my
parents lived until they were 22 there
so i have a lot of feelings towards it
but we grew up very like immigrant eight
family members in a studio apartment so
i i associate to humble beginnings
what what i guess here's the first
question were you an entrepreneurial kid
yeah by necessity you know it's one of
these things that
um
you know
everybody that has had some challenge as
a kid or in life i'm not gonna sit here
and say when i was eight years old
that i thought to myself wow you know
what this sucks but i'm building
resiliency i'll bet this will affect me
no
you didn't you didn't say attend my
favorite sentence of you know adversity
is the foundation of success yeah no i
just said this
but you know look there is
the things that i do think happened
is um
where i was in life made me comfortable
being uncomfortable
right and then the second thing
you know my mom
is that why you're petrified of 8th
place trophies because that's why i'm
petrified of them
like i'm not i'm not a big
look
i'm not a big particip participation
trophy person i think life whether you
like it or not keeps score
um and i think
that even with our foreign adversaries
at this point we're sort of wishing and
hoping that we lived in a different
world than we do right and i i i wonder
sometimes when i watch americans
screaming at each other
if if
if they don't understand that we have
foreign adversaries that are a true
challenge and that we keep taking our
eye off the ball yeah and i think if you
deploy any level of common sense and
understand scale and influence like
i would argue that it's already a
foregone conclusion like like there is
no scenario of our great great grandkids
not in a world where
you know china's only vulnerability is
people forget they're actually
communists and thus that's against the
human spirit and they'll have to figure
that out but china runs its
country the way we run businesses it's
communism with capitalism right like
every good company your legendary vayner
i promise you here's what it looks like
you empower people to do a ton of [ __ ]
but you at the tippy top
you're gonna make three to six decisions
that are not debatable they're just and
and so yeah i mean i think but i think
more taking it out of the macro in the
geopolitical
because i want to get this out of you
because now i've got a sense of your
philosophical framework which i think we
can extract some really cool insights
for some of the entrepreneurs and
executives that are listening
tell
actually before i make this assumption
would you argue
and i based on that hard pivot you made
i think we share another thing i'm
starting to sense
do you find yourself curious do you
think curiosity has helped you go down
some of these paths and because of that
curiosity you're coming in with fresh
eyes and when you come in with fresh
eyes sometimes you can see things that
the people that have been living in it
forever can't see anymore
well look i could tell you
uh intellectual curiosity has been a
staple of my life since i was a little
kid i i read
voraciously
eclectically
um and and i think that that's
extraordinarily important and once you
latch on to something
going down that rabbit hole and saying i
want to know everything there is to know
about this like it's something important
eclectically right like you're saying
things i want to make sure everybody
caught that because that was i thought
that was a very important word you're
saying like you may randomly find coin
collecting interesting out of left field
because you heard somebody say one thing
and then actually start reading and then
actually may go even and then you decide
actually after this first book i'm going
to go deep is that what you're saying
yeah i i think and whether that comes in
a business opportunity personal
satisfaction
and i i think also that
context with with learning and knowledge
is everything right if you can whether
it's history whether it's science i'm
i'm a huge believer in math and science
uh
you know i'm i'm on the board at
carnegie mellon and i'm on the uh
engineering school advisory board at mit
so i'm proximate to some pretty amazing
things that's some fancy bougie [ __ ]
there my friend
yeah
just i'm just standing next to them and
hoping i'll suppose this happens but you
know at the end of the day
that curiosity
and being
not only curious but hope but but trying
to get context around that so it's
either applicable
or you've built mental models and things
that allow pattern recognition to happen
i think all those things are extremely
important let me ask you a question that
really just popped up after this
enjoyable 20 minutes
do you believe that
being underestimated
is a tremendous advantage and gift
that's an interesting question because i
think sometimes
yes
being underregarded allows you
the opportunity to grow without people
trying to stop that growth
there are other times when you want to
cut through all the crap and just say
look
let's
let's try to fast forward to the real
thing because there's another so what
you're saying there is
because you value actual execution and
practicality
that after putting some wins on the
board in your life that that reputation
allows you in that meeting setting or
board room or
whatever environment is to maybe speed
up
the waste
no question about it because look there
is a certain point where you've done
enough in your career
to not have to explain either who you
are
or hey what about when you're innovating
at scale so for example
one thing that i find interesting about
my career is i pivot so much
and even though i continuously put wins
on the board when you're going to
something so new it's almost like you're
doing the same thing all over again and
i also think and i've come to realize
this in my mid-40s now
that oh i actually enjoy being
underestimated i like being an underdog
this is probably why i'm a jets fan by
the way uh you know um
but because i do that to myself there is
a level of like having to repeat certain
things um
and i'm but at the same token to your
point which is why i use that analogy i
do enjoy
this point of my career where i could be
like hey can we just get to this point
because talk about somebody who's
obsessed with seven minute meetings i
don't want to waste one minute because
it's the only resource besides health
that i care about and
i don't want to have a 45 minute meeting
pandering to people's insecurities and
lack of knowledge of the subject matter
let's just get to the punch line and
collectively do something here
look i think that's absolutely right and
i i it's always interesting to me that
people are willing to waste money
um
or i'm sorry miss speaking the exact
opposite that they obsess over saving
money but up time the time is like oh
you know i can because i i doubt
that anybody on their deathbed says
bring me my financial statements not one
person right so that's a regret by the
way
well one of the things that speaks to me
just in terms of reading and so forth is
stoicism right it's hard to apply every
day
but i i find if if you haven't read
marcus aurelius or you know any of the
stoics it's worth visiting
and one of the things that they talk
about ryan holiday oh ryan's a good
friend so ryan
has been enjoying the last five years
just whispering to me
like taking clips of me and being like
do you know how much of a stoic you are
and i'm actually very interesting i love
information but i've come to learn
i haven't really gotten classified
though i may it just takes time back to
what we're talking about i clearly have
a massive reading comprehension issue
so i i don't read books obviously i read
a lot of micro and i listen and watch a
lot
but
he just gets a kick out of it and it's
interesting you're bringing it up
because he's really pounding up me on
like how much i am it
well look i i ryan's a great guy great
author
um big thinker
and i a lot of their philosophy speaks
to me just because
you worry about what you control
and you know their whole thing is you
you should contemplate death every day
not in a morbid way but just to say look
we all have an expiration date right and
if kovid hasn't shoved that like right
up in your face
that you know you need to really focus
on not only what's important but even
relationships people you care about
you know making sure that you continue
to cultivate that
so it's something i at least try to say
to myself did i do a good job today of
spending time on things that matter
and that there's real yield
before we get you out of here
since we're running out of time
i want to go current events in business
um because i'm going to take advantage
now that i understand how much i enjoy
your macro let's go little micro
where if anywhere are you with your
curiosity or
digging into of nfts
well i have a number of investments in
that world and obviously we're hearing
all kinds of monikers now right there's
there's nft uh there there's there's
tokens there's crypto there's web 3.0
all these different things
and i do have a number of uh of
investments
uh in that world the thing that's
interesting to me that i'm trying to
watch
is what is the intrinsic value
going to be and how will it stand the
test of time and sort itself out
there's no question in my mind
that digital
goods right if we assign value to them
that is no different than hey i have a
baseball card and it has a value because
other people say
right it's it's a shared myth sort of
thing
um the thing that's interesting to me
about crypto is what happens when
governments
writ large sort of say
okay
now this currency has the full faith and
credit of the us of whatever it is it's
going to be really interesting to watch
what that policy looks looks like
the tax situation
how all of that is going to unfold
i have some very very smart friends in
in deep finance that tell me that they
think this will be one of the biggest
sort of opportunities and transfer of
wealth in human history as this thing
unfolds yeah so i'm trying to
participate
but also
yeah and just because i don't
i don't quote where it's going let me do
a little more wrap around i apologize i
love the in-depth questions
movie theaters
given your background
state of the union of the movie theater
business hot takes two three sentences
what are you thinking
tough business going forward i don't
think movies are going anywhere you
think they can innovate to go super like
i keep wondering would i pay why am i
willing to pay 400 for a sushi night
like there's got to be a way to get me
to pay 300 bucks for the new batman
there's got to be no well but the
question is do you need that large box
piece of real estate which you're
talking to someone who loves going to
the movies that communal experience
that's my point right the community like
like the answer is no but the but the
world is and now instead of ore
right like sometimes i want to sit and
like i watch the lucille ball thing on
amazon prime i didn't need to go to the
theater for that you know
uh a marvel versus dc crossover super
film of justice league versus you know
like avengers
with you know i don't know i could see
myself wanting to especially you know i
like the head-to-head [ __ ] that could be
really fun in the theater to see who
likes the one side or the other yeah i
think the other challenge is just the
appointment nature of it so if i need to
go out at 7 40 park a car go inside but
you're so willing to do that for dinner
so many times a month
look the the question is though
if you have a 60 inch flat screen at
home in high def
or for
this is a combo of and right to your
point the experience now is so i mean
look you and i how old are you my friend
i am 51. you look great so i'm 46 we've
had the same basic thing right
ghostbusters comes out you know that if
you don't go see it there
that you're not going to see it
for 18 months on vhs and you're going to
be on your shitty team like it's like
right so be your point but i still think
the communal and then i still think food
and beverage you know i know these some
of these things have popped up right i
went to one in naples you can get a nice
little glass of wine but i still don't
think they broke the format listen we've
we've run out of time i i would love to
do this again in the future i loved
i really enjoyed this me too thank you
very much for having me on
thanks for being on
you